and then eh e ffort I don't know if I
can ban with Eddie and Jo on Saturday
yes and I'd love to ask Eddie i-beam
Toni's coach I would have thrown in the
towel in the fourth well we're gonna get
to that yeah because I I think that it
looked like to me like what was so
impressive about just engag is that he
looked like he was doing basic great
kicks ridiculous kicks and then basic
boxing just countering left right hook
you know hook right his angles it's his
angles which aren't big this is footwork
it's really hard to be that good it did
see he's been with he said I've been
working with Trevor Woodman for nine
years so those little subtleties that
you can't really even pick up where he's
stepping when he hits where his head is
that that wasn't even his leg kicks if
you watch the way he was leg kicking his
head was out of like a lot of times when
you leg kick your liability getting
punched in the face that's with time in
life that [ __ ] would just have
his head it's really hard to deal with
him I thought he fought such a patient
perfect fight you said I mean you said
to me I don't know if you said on that
podcast but you said it's a terrible
fight for Tony yeah because you got a
because Justin just stands there and
bangs and well Tony's gift and what he's
amazing at his number one he's his
endurance is off the charts number two
he's very creative with his punching
number three he just never let you
breathe he just keeps coming at you and
hits you everywhere it seems that just
engage he that's not the way to fight
just engaging it's just not the way to
fight cuz like I would see Justin versus
khabib because I watched a you know a
voice I think every fight Tony Ferguson
has ever had he does get hit a lot
I mean he gets taken down he gets hit it
it's don't ease it he likes it anywhere
it doesn't he's like cool you did that
to me for three rounds here how we do is
expect that really guys to kind of
tailor off right exhausting Justin get
just kept though it's tough to do any
and punch in the face man
nothing drains our cardio more than
punched in yeah I hate seeing he's so
rough I would have to cuz he's just too
tough for his own good yeah that's where
you have cornermen and live to fight
another day
well then the other thing I say with a
lot of respect but it's but I just have
to say it I don't believe anybody I
don't care how great you are
I don't believe that anybody
you can take a beating that he took from
Justin Goethe and not be different
afterwards so great yeah IIIi just I've
seen it everything evidences on your
side you look at JD s when he fought
cane yes gets T pay when he fought
Francis Ghana remember yes he did work
and threats ain't a ton of shots yeah he
gets knocked out in the following fight
against DC against not that hard of a
punch
yeah that's right hey we can go through
I can I could come on yeah and and
that's just how the brain and the head
works and everything else and he when he
shook his head when he was like he did
this weird eerie shake it was so it was
just eerie it was just it was cringing I
just was like you got to stop this
didn't anybody he'll die in did him yeah
but that's what he says let me die in
there anybody else have audio issues
with their pay-per-view I didn't I
remember that part audio issues I don't
know yeah I said I'd heard one or two
bit oh you know it was driving me nuts
I've gotta mention some below-the-belt
what's driving me [ __ ] nuts
was the vh1 pop up video tweet oh my god
now hey man he's a [ __ ] pain what the
fine oh man and then you could tell
fighters just doing it to get on TV I
know damn this fight it's crazy damn
these these bros are throwing has
checked the only way I paid money for
this the only one I loved was no comment
by cab even that was the only one I
don't see any of it do ya leave the
social meet up my [ __ ] I agree I
agree
give me the fight by the way how growl
said you know how amateur that looked at
Oh
these huge fights and blink boy these
boys are throwing yeah just these
general random comment right now get the
[ __ ] out of here right now
but what was really cool is hearing the
impact like because the crowd was the
best was the father's listen to DC and
his coaching was what was what no
fighters could hear DC critiquing like
Oh Greg Carr could hear it Greg Cardenas
throw like cakes are he should do it yet
and they would pick it up and damn it's
how good DC is as a commentator yeah of
course
the best of course I'm listening [ __ ]
BC when I can but I I I'm very intrigued
at the just engage he khabib great fight
because I think could be painful he's
got his hands full I mean hands full as
long as he doesn't try to stand a bang
with Justin because I think he's gonna
have to
just like with Donna you you I don't
know how you feel about this that the
fight I'd love to see actually love to
see its Conor McGregor just engag
because I think actually I think Conor
beat them well I think Connors are
better but again overall better striker
in that more precise more tightly I
don't know if his leg kicks are as good
as Justin's Justin would cause Justin
would cause a lot of problems for Juke
fern for Conrad there really to get kit
he's not that works too good he's in and
out he got to be stationary stationary
fact if Justin tried to go bang with I
think I think for Justin it goes Justin
khabib they want to get crazy there go
Justin Connor throwing him a payday but
look it up the look in that it's so
strange because could be poor a poor a
beat'em right I'm sorry for a beat
Justin poor a beat Justin so it's just
about stylistically matchups are better
for certain guys it just so happens on
this god-given earth Justin gave matches
up bet against Tony forcing khabib then
the rest of the division so I was
travelling is that yes he just has to
get their eggs there and then now it's
off to the races I was trying to ask how
long he's gonna hold the belt because if
he wins and then what gonna be champ
I think Connor is a nightmare for just
engage he see I was trying to avoid this
right avoid the the temptation to jump
on the just during full force but he's
the greatest because like you said with
styles and he's not a task in certain
styles styles it Styles yeah I mean if
he's if he has to bang with Connor I
think Connors ultimately I think Connor
doesn't Bay I thought it would anything
I think Pat Connor would have done the
same thing to tell me Ferguson probably
I think Connor would have I think I
think kind of that if that Tony showed
up that night yeah yes I think I I don't
know if Connor hits it hard as just
engag though Justin gay she hits very
Hans knocked out record would beg the
differ you'd say Connor hit that's true
look what Connor did to Nate Diaz who's
a giant 170 how many times he dropped
them I'm gonna knock him out but who
does knock out nobody no knocks out the
Diaz brothers but yeah he knocked him
down four times I'm crazy so you saw
it's all about matchups and what the UFC
wants to do but now that now they you
know they kind of have their gamut
that's assuming that's assume
gauging its Baike beam I'm back on the
Connor train and I got Connor I've never
loved brother I I've got I got Connor
cause if his learning IQ his ability he
does the same thing that say I'm on
college trait if he wants it and I know
he's training I'm on the counter trend
yeah now he's throw miles at all in the
fifty oh god I keep forgetting about him
but he's yeah isn't he fighting at 70 or
Aziz now you'd fight Connor at 55 man
now we got some yeah they're some
[ __ ] monsters at 55 so but it's
interesting is like how it affects you
because if Justin gets the belt then
Connors probably give me your champ by
then the 2020 right or two thousand
begin a 2.21 but if could be both the
belt
it's tough fight for Connor but then
Mazel it all could be gonna get back in
the country
that's another quail yeah yeah he will
that make that happen or you're gonna go
to him or you can go to fight I like a
[ __ ] fight we're gonna fly you
private to fight Island that's true just
happening it's joke this is all gonna go
on oh these she's pressing it how great
is it I saw the numbers are good we
don't know the numbers but I hope
they're a great source is company that
runs with so Hogan no not boho no a
friend that works with the agency Tilian
indoors and now just so you guys know
that they represent the you doesn't mean
William Morris he means
chili chili lemon and George chili
endorsed and Doris Julie endorse
representative told me that it the
papery numbers aren't great now that's
just hearsay that's like oh you haven't
that the immediate numbers that quick
well but they can see the initial surge
and see if it's somewhere oh I think I
think an agency that rhymes with well
that rhymes with Jillian Doris is in
trouble is finally funded by bankruptcy
yes you know sometimes you make bad
calculations and our virus comes oh you
have seats 49 sold more than double
already double them what your C
experience on believe a pacing of
pay-per-view great yeah I hope it goes
right that's what it looks like
pre-event buys oh that's good
hmm but here's that you never know you
do you it's like Disneyland
we don't know turn did you see Tony's
Tony Ferguson's dance on his ramen
yeah the hospital yeah yeah to that 90s
that early 90s our music didn't rat or
sound yet working below the belt
yeah now he's still in the hospital I
take it after when I or bill and their
precious scanned and stuff that was a
rough one dude I see a picture that's
his girl such a stud he's just a
different dude he's a very special human
being man mm-hmm
he really is he's a special [ __ ]
human being I I you know the best yeah I
know it's the fight game I just love to
watch I [ __ ] hate seeing that I do
agree with you I think it I think if I
was his corner I would throw the towel I
would have I want to look to his face
now would've been like I don't like this
it's not where the style he's not a
knockout artist and there was no sign
there's gonna not get you out really so
it's like what are we doing dude yeah
live to fight another day
so hard would have been really upset but
I think weeks later like probably the
best yeah so hard to do it in his corner
though when you're dealing with a
warrior like that it means that you have
Corman I guess fire you may he might
fire you I mean that's fine
you protect himself for the longevity
yeah yeah that was a great uppercut
right there right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]